March Madness brackets we're gonna get
to touch it and then and and look at it
and massage it and and then talk about
bubbles being burst that's all right
there everyone loves at that time of
year just in time also to snuggle up
with this new book that I have right
here on the desk Seth Davis getting to
us how great coaches make great teams
and the author and a man who's been
covering college hoops forever and a day
for CBS Sports and Sports Illustrated
good to see you so to see rich I love
the juxtaposition of the book next to
this mug
okay I'm gonna steal a mug by the way
people steal these because I intend to
steal this the mug is yours to keep um
and you can keep that book very good
book for a mug who stole a coaster JK
Simmons Oscar win case Simmons pocketed
the coaster on the way out he did he
five finger discount at a coaster which
is fine with us the man's an Emmy and
Oscar Award winner he is an Ohio State
guy and he would be very pleased to see
Urban Meyer on the cover of this book so
you spoke to urban who did you speak to
for this book to learn about what makes
cook all of them so they're nine coaches
in the book yes six basketball three
football so the basketball coaches are
Mike sous chef ski Jim Boeheim Tom Izzo
Geno Auriemma
Doc Rivers and Brad Stevens and my
football coaches are Jim Harbaugh from
your alma mater Urban Meyer and Dabo
Sweeney and access became I didn't know
this going in this access became very
important to this book so each chat
these are deep dives each chapter is
each coaches a chapter each chapter is
10,000 words plus that great access to
all these guys went back from multiple
conversations and more importantly they
connected me with their wives then the
nine wives were the best interviews in
the book because they know their men the
best and also they're easier to get on
the phone as well as you know parents
and you know Jim Harbaugh connected me
with his brother obviously was important
kids colleagues players to really
examine how these men form their
worldview a lot of times they'd say to
me I feel like I'm in therapy and they
were because it starts with the dad
right it starts with how your
relationship with your dad or maybe you
don't have a good relationship with your
dad and that's how you form that's your
formative early experience your
childhood your education your early path
in your career the adversity the
struggles that you go through I develop
what I call the peak profile PE a Kay
isolating these four characteristics
persistence empathy authenticity and
knowledge
so that's peak and then you know how
they created those characters heuristics
how they you know went about growing up
learning their craft and then how do
they apply it to the players in their
locker room that's getting to us where
you're taking a disparate group of
individuals and you're trying to create
a cohesive unit where everybody they may
have different individual agendas but
you get them all working towards the
same goal and over time these nine guys
have shown pretty consistently they're
good at getting their teams to us so was
there through long
is there a through line that you found
but you know what's nine guys a common
thread is that there is no common thread
that's what I found like you look at Jim
Harbaugh on the sidelines he's a raving
maniac you look at Brad Stevens on the
sidelines you wonder if the guy even has
a pulse so there that's what the
authenticity piece comes in there is no
one way to do this but there is one way
to do this for you and it might be
different for you then it's for somebody
else so it's having to you know figure
out who you are cuz if you're if you're
inauthentic your players will see
through that like that and they won't
follow but I will say this like we're
talking before we came on about John
Beilein who was you know brilliant and
so what's the secret sauce and really
again there is no secret sauce it's the
application and of your craft and the
development and learning minute by
minute hour by hour day by day week by
week growing year by year growing
learning developing making small
decisions along the way the hundreds
thousands of decisions that a coach has
to make over the course of the season
and then doing that over a long period
of time as you slowly develop that's the
secret sauce how about this Seth Davis
I'm well you know we're gonna get to the
NC double-a tournament bracket etc etc
shortly here your book getting to us how
great coaches make great teams available
right now bookstores and online because
it came out just a couple of days ago
how about this is that each guy and I
haven't read your book again and you
haven't really drank from my mug in
working on that that each guy has a full
knowledge of what he'd likes to do on
the court on the field
understands a system finds players for
the system and also is fortunate enough
to have found early success in their
careers so they don't get poop can't as
it happens here in this business you
know what I'm saying that there yeah
that each I'm just think about the top
of the head eater that urban in Utah
dabble obviously in Clemson
Harbaugh at San Diego and then Stanford
etc etc of sous chefs key we can go on
and on and on right but all of these
guys Belichick even though he didn't
have success early on in Cleveland they
all know beeline knows I've got a system
I got enough find the right players I
got to see the heartbeat inside and they
have a certain sixth sense about that
heartbeat and that's what makes them
good and that's empathy so people think
of empathy like sympathy they're
actually different sympathy means you
feel bad for somebody empathy means you
feel what they are feeling you
understand how they think you know some
guys you know you got to really get
under their skin and and and get up
there but to motivate them other guys if
you yell at them they wilt and then you
know they need you to put your arm
around them so it's being able to
discern those differences you know just
an example like Mike sous-chefs key
about adapting over time one of the
things that he told me that he does is
he makes a point because he's 72 years
old he's coaching a team full of humble
it's unbelievable and he's coaching a
team full of college freshmen and
they're still getting to us why well you
know what he makes a point to listen to
their music because he wants to feel
what they're feeling and he wants to
experience what they're experiencing and
then they see him listening to a while
he's working out or in his car and then
he's talking to the team he might make
reference to one of their songs and
their attention perks up because he's
saying I'm in your world so that's the
that's the empathy piece and you know
she said she is someone who did struggle
early in his career and so you have
setbacks and you have you know Bill
Belichick getting fired in Cleveland I
mean Doc Rivers getting fired in Orlando
but then also other there's all kinds of
adversity I mean Doc Rivers you know he
grew up in in Maywood Illinois suburb of
Chicago amidst a lot of racial strife in
the late 60s early 70s he goes to
Marquette he's a good player at
Marquette and he starts dating a white
girl who becomes his wife and they
encounter a lot of you know racial
hatred over that
and then when he was living in Orlando
excuse me in San Antonio his house got
burned down by an arsonist that they
thought was racially motivated and then
later on in his life he's the coach of
the LA Clippers and he's got the dollar
Donald sterling bombshell that now he's
got to deal with young african-americans
in his locker he was remarkable he was
remarkable so all of so and you can't
explain how Doc Rivers handled the
Donald sterling situation unless you
explain about his dad the cop and his
mom and her faith in her spirit and
growing up amidst racial violence and
seeing when Proviso wins the state
championship how all the whites and the
blacks in the stands who've been
literally throwing bottles at each other
earlier in the day are celebrating the
team's success in the unifying force of
sports and that prepared Doc Rivers to
handle the Donald sterling mess that's
what the book is about Seth Davis
getting to us how great coaches make
great teams new book go check it out I
want to talk before we take a break and
then hit the the tournament about Brad
Stevens because he would be I guess out
of all the ones that you mentioned the
least well known about what makes him
tick we saw what happened with Butler
and man oh man to Danny Ainge see
something in him that was that was
obviously perfect for the NBA and just
his just the way he's demeanor his
concepts the way he goes about his job
he just always seems in a sport where I
think we've seen all the offenses we've
seen all the schemes he seems to come up
with wrinkles that no one else sees what
makes him tick best you can tell you
know people call Brad Stevens a genius
and I think that's actually a little bit
of an insult okay because that implies
that he's smarter than them because you
are yes it's an insult the genius um it
implies that it comes easily for him
that I just you know just kind of things
under my monument Brad Stevens and he
really if maybe more than any other
coaches that interviewed he really until
took me inside his process okay and we
went like through his game day
hour-by-hour and how many hours he
spends here like one thing he does is he
makes a rule never to sleep on airplanes
because he doesn't want to be cramming
so he has a process where he watches the
last three games of each opponent and it
takes him two hours in each game and he
breaks down what he needs and then he
has his little template where he takes
his notes and then he has a pad of
templates that he's
developed over the years that he takes
his notes and he wills it down further
into his game sheet that he puts in his
pocket and he almost never has to take
it out of his pocket because through
that process he knows what's there part
of his process on game day this is
actually how it lead his chapter is he
plays 20 minutes of miss pac-man
everybody all the parents out there
telling you're like me telling my sons
don't play in a video games as part of
his game day process when he's at home
he's got a little console that his wife
got for me 20 minutes of miss pac-man it
has two benefits one it's just like what
he calls his his mindfulness I tried to
kiss him on you don't have in the studio
by the way which is like so much nicer
than Dan Patrick's I want to say this is
an amazing studio that's a new drop
there you go
so it's it's like a moment of
mindfulness for him he's not
superstitious he's not like super anal
like he couldn't even adjust his routine
but he likes his routine sure and also
you know the other benefit is it makes
him really good at miss pac-man so when
someone comes over and they want to play
with miss pac-man he's gonna be - a miss
pac-man and he's gonna talk about
beating on those pac-man so having
covered Brad at Butler and gonna know
him well and the phrase I was used with
him as don't let the smooth taste fool
you he looks like he just got bar
Mitzvahed the nicest got the nicest guy
in the world he's got this great
sideline demeanor where he never not
only is he never upset he he never
celebrates a win he's always stoic
believe me more than he wants to win he
hates to lose and he is intensely
intensely competitive and of really
impressive and a very probably the most
likable guy in the book I have the
Celtics has got a winner there's no
doubt about it obviously um I just he
came on the show about a year ago would
love to chatting with him I just he's a
nice guy right I'll just not humble and
young and and the Celtics just they they
don't have to make a change for a long
time yeah and they've got a system that
that that they clearly have the right
players for I'm a big fan of Brad
Stevens yeah that's oh that's an in your
book right here one last thing so he
doesn't sleep on airplanes where you on
the planes with him I was not all planes
with him but you know I talked to you
know others with him but like he dated
his wife in college and she said like
when it came to finals you know she'd be
up all night cramming he never had to
cram because he had it kind of paced out
here's what I need and then you know by
the way when the test is over
forgot the material so it's not like
he's this genius he just knows how to
take information prepare it get his
system and routine down so when that
Bell comes and he needs to answer it he
knows exactly what he wants to do it
certainly helps with back-to-backs it
certainly helps in an NCAA tournament
when he was going through all that do
you know if he takes his shoes off on a
plane you know I don't know that'll be
in the sequel that guy over there that I
did that selfie shows up on the plane
yes on the plane is that a bad thing
thank you thank you so you don't take
your shoes off on the plane I do I'll
take my socks off
exactly what help animals I mean it's
not your home can recline you can
recline you can recline they want you to
feel at home though the two of you guys
all right when we come back we'll hit
the NCAA tournament who might be on the
bubble who might not be who you think
should be a top seed or a two seed in
Detroit because they've won back-to-back
Big Ten championships can't imagine a
Michigan that's next year on the Rich
Eisen show with Seth Davis back for a
minute 20 before the radio audience
rejoins us you just said you saw Billy
Joel at the garden took my son's here
from New York I'm from Maryland
originally at the New York and went to
summer camp with half of Long Island so
right Billy Joel though the summer camp
crowded that's that's a big Thomas Billy
Joel at the garden it was great I saw
him at the garden at once it was the
night where after which he went to rehab
really yeah Wow
it was him and Elton John together yeah
they remember touring together yeah I'm
and and and we say it again I saw them
at the Dome and Billy I think had a
little bit too much yeah
so when when he was singing goodnight
Saigon and he gave the tribute to all
the veterans in the Vietnam War place
went nuts and he said to all the
veterans out there for the Korean War
place went nuts all the veterans out
there for World War two place went nuts
and he goes and for all you veterans out
there world war one in there and there
was kind of polite applause and then all
those of those who fought in the Civil
War
and we're kind of beginning to look at
each other and then he starts going in
the war of 1812 and the Spanish met like
literally was started going back and we
just start looking at you look what the
big history channel guy the middle and
then suddenly after that song
Elton did the rest of the night is that
right roll your bride there you go
all right sup Davis back here on the
Rich Eisen show we just got a deep dive
into his new book getting to us how
great coaches make great teams talk to
some of the best in the business of
football and basketball college and pro
joining me here now are just mere days
before selection sunday goes down who do
you think their teams that need to be
very concerned about not hearing their
names on Sunday night give me some names
well there are a lot of your colleagues
our colleagues in the sports media
business who are concerned about
Syracuse as they should be I think
they're pretty much out Notre Dame's got
a big one today against Duke Notre
Dame's a fascinating case because they
played most of the season without their
best player bonzi Colson who's not just
their best player really a first-team
all-america caliber player so they don't
have the resume of a team that could get
in but now that they have him back and
he's playing well does the committee
give them that leeway I think probably
not without a win over Duke today but
that is uh that is something and then
you know Arizona State finished I want
to say they finished the season three
games under 500 in the pac-12 which
normally you would say no chance but
they got wins over Kansas and Xavier
early in the season at one point they
are ranked in the top five of the
country they have a neutral court win
over Kansas State which would be
important because you're comparing
bubble teams so I think they probably
get in but the fact that a team that on
Christmas Day was ranked third in the AP
poll is now basically on the verge of
not being in a lot of people time at
Oklahoma with Trey young obviously they
really tanked it down the stretch I
think they've got enough house money to
probably get in there they lost last
night yeah they lost again last night at
Oklahoma State is playing Kansas today
they've beaten Kansas twice Kansas
playing today without their starting
center as a bouquet and they have very
little frontcourt depth to begin with
the vocal home estate wins today they've
made a pretty good case to get in so
let's just say Oklahoma and Trey young
don't make it okay and they're an NIT in
the NFL we have seen play
who are gonna be surefire draft picks
sit out bowl games that mean nothing do
you think we might be in the era of a
one-and-done player interesting I
thought playing an NIT game cuz they
don't want to get hurt I haven't even
thought about that or heard anybody say
that it's a fascinating question I mean
I mean you know Ben Simmons and Markel
volts you know I don't think the other
teams made the NIT cuz you got to be
over 500 I mean football there's a much
bigger chance of getting hurt sure and
seriously hurt than in the basketball
game so clearly I would guess know and
knowing Trey a little bit knowing his
family pretty well I would guess no but
I wouldn't begrudge him I don't begrudge
any of these guys at that point doing
whatever's best for them like I got my
own kids to race problems normally I
don't need to raise up other people's
kids still the same way about the
one-and-done Seth Davis here on the Rich
Eisen show what and then before we get
to that top seeds where are we still on
the air here three you're locked in it
so I don't happen locked in Virginia
Villanova Xavier done they don't have to
win another game they're number one see
it's got it Kansas is a little bit of a
closer call because they have a couple
of not-so-great losses but really the
only team that I think can get to that
one line over a Kansas is Duke so if
Duke wins the ACC tournament which would
presumably include wins over North
Carolina and Virginia if Kansas loses
today Duke actually doesn't have as many
quality wins as you might think if you
get into the nitty gritty nerd stuff of
the RPI and the quadrant one is like the
new big thing but it is conceivable that
Duke could get to the one line all the
other candidates you know Michigan State
Michigan Cincinnati Auburn was the SEC
champ I just don't see them as number
one seed so right we're a bit more
settled in I've been I think we're used
to at this part of the week does it even
matter anymore do you think you know
it's funny like I've never known why the
number one seed thing matters to anybody
like you got to play the game so maybe
the 16 is a little bit weaker than a 15
but you know beyond that I mean it's all
about matchups and it's a great upon
verse Asian it's like a feather in your
cap to be a one that's not gonna buy two
right I mean we've seen the 15 seeds
Rock even just obviously Tom Izzo really
yeah you've seen that that's much more
of a positive 16 the 16 beating of one
is like the only thing left in sports
that's never happened you know I
this baby with Clark Kellogg is like
it's never gonna happen not in our
lifetime I'm like we've had overtime
games between 16s and ones we've had
single-digit margins between 16s and
ones you see where the you know the
trend lines in terms of the parity going
on sometimes you get a 16 seed with who
for whatever reason is good as good as a
15 seed and maybe a one who isn't so
strong like it's only a matter of time
before it happens I think a couple more
minutes left here with Seth Davis before
you head to your head all right to the
New York don't go into a snowstorm and
then I'm going to land a Saturday night
and then I'm in Atlanta all next week
okay for winter with the folks at Turner
so what is going on with Arizona what is
happening how does Seth Miller get sent
homes on the Oregon is re your middle
name is Seth by the way my middle name I
just learned that diploma on the wall so
how does Shawn Miller gets sent home
from Oregon only to be completely
rehabilitated and sent out there by the
administration with a full-throated
cherub a barrel-chested denial yeah it
was ESPN is standing behind
I was impressive on Shawn's part I don't
know that he's been fully rehabilitated
it is very difficult rich and you know
you've been in this business a long time
it's really difficult to get good heart
information right now everything is
under seal you know the feds dropped all
these claims early on here's what we
have and then everything's kind of been
under seal behind closed doors we've had
a couple of media leaks you know there's
some indication on the reporting from
the seat so this ESPN report drops on
Saturday morning and they're playing
that night I mean it was a bombshell
report and so it's hard for both Shawn
and his attorneys and the schools and
their attorneys and their boards and
everything to figure out what's going on
DeAndre Aten was the player his freshman
who's gonna be the number one pick in
the draft who's the one that mentioned
the story there's some indication in the
reporting that if Shawn was on a wiretap
saying these things that he may have
been talking about a different player
other than the Andre aidan Severns
likewise eight in playing but Miller's
not code right so that's that's possible
as well but the real question is how
does Arizona the University of Arizona
get the information they need to be able
to make this decision if Shawn Miller
saying it's not true I didn't
do it I've never paid players then so I
think they were just kind of hitting the
pause button and saying look let's have
him not coached tonight because it's
gonna be a circus he's got a tough talk
to the media after the game let's get
all our ducks in a row and then they
took a few days to sift through and they
just didn't have any information that
would lead them to say Sean Miller can't
coach so Sean Miller was very steadfast
in denial he didn't say well I may have
been talking about but not talking about
someone else he's saying this never
happened I've never arranged payment
I've never done this and so he's out
there if we get evidence to the contrary
he's gonna have to pay the cops people
say well do you believe my said well I
would want to believe him that's not my
job to believe him it's not it's my job
to react to facts and right now the
facts are very very limited in this case
rich this is an NCAA case this is a prop
being prosecuted by the United States
Attorney of the Southern District of New
York it's going to take a long time the
year to two years before we really know
what's happened here so all of this all
these predictions about the house is
burning down and the college-basketball
apocalypse is coming it's gonna be a
while before we really know what's going
well in that case to just last one for
you before we send you to LAX we had B
line on the show yesterday and I said
based you know on what he thinks needs
to be done it sure sounds like
everyone's looking at the NBA because
the NCAA is ineffectual and they're
looking at the NBA and he basically said
well the NBA kind of controls when
somebody can come there is that where
the fix is here what are you the one in
doughnuts a problem with nothing to do
with any of this and one another FEX
maybe three to five players a year max
so you're telling me that all these
other players who go to college who
weren't good enough to go to the NBA to
high school they're not gonna take money
something's gonna offer the money
they're not gonna take it so you know
I'll say this on the one-and-done first
of all when people say the one-and-done
is heard in college basketball let's
remember before there was one and none
there was none and done so from a
business standpoint is college
basketball better with DeAndre Aiden and
Marvin Bagley in college or in the NBA
it's a no-brainer me personally I think
if the Boston Celtics want to draft a 13
year old kid and pay him millions of
dollars he should be able to do that
like I said I've got enough problems
raising my own kids without worrying
about anybody else's so I'm open for you
know free market opportunities it is an
NBA rule
the Players Association doesn't want any
any minimum the owners want it to be 20
because that means they have to pay them
less money over the course of their
careers because they're getting fewer
bytes at the free-agent apple it's all
about money
but the NBA it's all about money with
the NCAA let's all just agree that it's
about money and separate whatever people
are concerned about with the 1 I'm done
with a much broader problem which is
that this amateur is a model is woefully
outdated and it's unfortunate that it
takes a crisis to provoke real change
but I am hopeful with this commission
that Marc Cameron has established and
the track that he's trying to put them
on that in the agent space and I'll let
kids having better contact with agents
and maybe there's some financial
transactions in the form of loans maybe
they can make some money signing
autographs open it up they're not
they're not opening it up free fro Wild
West paper play that is not gonna happen
but they need to have some real
significant change and I am hopeful that
out of the ashes by the time next season
comes around we're gonna have a much
better and it won't be perfect but a
much better system a better amateur as a
model alright now you're free to move
about the cabin
thank you head to LAX thank you well I I
I will I'm gonna take my shoes off but
off I'll feel a little bad about it I
will still there might be somebody
sitting next you like these guy looks
really fine to me but I have no idea
what his hygiene is and why is he
putting me in the position to wonder
about it why is not about someone else's
hygiene because point you know you don't
want you know just wondering what is you
know I just Seth Davis looks on the
up-and-up I know he's got a new book out
called getting nose there you go I
understand that but you know I don't
want the smell getting to me thank you
so much good to see you I appreciate
your thank you come on back any time any
come on back the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience